欢迎你学习白泽国际站运营实战系统课
同学们前面我们已经讲了在行业的维度里面怎么样去分析市场
第六小节我们来讲一下在确定类幕后如何去分析国家的市场
重点是从国家这个维度进行系统的分析的
首先第一步就是我们点击查国家
查国家的之后这里有一些类幕可以选择
我们可以去确定类幕之后来选这些我们要主要做的
目标市场, 这些就是我们要做的目标市场, 也就是在这个内幕下, 哪些国家更加喜欢这个内幕, 或者是说, 他在这个内幕的流量会更大, 选对了国家之后, 比如说我们刚才确定了美国这个国家是吧, 第二个维度, 比如说我选择的是这个内幕, 国家, 我选择美国, 美国了之后, 我选择具体的30天, 30天之后, 也就是我市场洞察, 是针对这个内幕下,
这个国家的市场进行分析, 那么这里面分析的这些数据维度, 都是针对这个类目下, 这个美国的整体的数据, 那么我们从这些维度, 我们就可以看出, 比如说, 我们先分析美国买家的画像, 这个是美国, 美国它在这个类目下的中端价比是什么样的, APP77%, PC是21.8%,
如果我们在这里切换个国家, 英国, 把它切换成英国, 那么这里的数据, 这里的数据都是会变化的, NOQ偏好的话, 我们也可以看一下美国, 它的NOQ主要是偏好哪些NOQ, 你看, 占比最大的就是中高, 同时呢, 美国这个国家, 在这个类目下, 他们的买家排名是第一, 也就是全球最多买家在美国, 他占了整个平台的,
40, 2.32%, 你看, 差不多占了50%, 说明什么, 说明这个类目下, 美国的采购是非常多的, 所以说我们可能就会优先考虑先做美国市场, 如果在这个类目下, 我们的产品, 款式, 价格, 等等都比较符合美国的, 那么我们就优先做美国市场, 那么最后面我们来讲解一个逻辑, 就是在这个类目下, 美国这个国家, 全球,
买家数占比大小, 判断市场是否容易做, 如果买家数排名很靠后面, 而且买家数占比很小, 那么说明这个类目下, 这个市场容量小, 而且它的流量是比较难获得的, 成交的概率会很小, 所以这就是我们在确定类目下, 去选择我们目标市场的国家去做, 接下来我们再看一些比较详细的
数据维度, 比如说我们国家已经定了, 是吧, 就刚才我们说的那个美国, 找到了这个国家的高增长的品类, 流量大的品类, 我们再来看一下它的终端, 还有Q, 还有它的采购规模等等, 这些维度怎么样去判断呢, 第一个, 在具体的国家和具体的内幕下的数据, 这个是具体国家, 也就是刚才我说的美国跟具体选择的内幕下的数据, 这个是近180天内的数据,
那么这个采购规模
它是判断这个类目和这个国家的买家质量
判断买家大小的类型的一个占比
这个就非常的关键了,很多人说
为什么我推广的
一些国家来的寻盘很多
成交的都是小单
为什么都是小单呢
你看一下这个占比就非常关键了, 采购规模就是说
你的买家的质量跟大小
都可以从这里判断的出来
比如说你的这个国家
它本身这些什么交易额占比都是非常大的, 而且下面这些占据比例非常大, 说明什么? 说明这个国家的买家非常大
它的质量肯定是相对来说比较好的
因为它都是交易额都是比较大的
但是如果你的内幕下定的某个国家, 比如说非洲的某个国家
你一去看
所有的采购额都是在一万以下
而且它占比占到了95%以上, 说明非洲的国家, 无论你怎么去获取流量, 那么它的整体的交易额都是很小的
所以对于我们想要获取高质量的买家来说, 选对国家是非常重要的, 一定要重视这个板块, 按照这个逻辑去选择你要主推的国家
不然你会发现真的流量很多, 悬盘也很多, 但是, 质量很差, 订单很小, 就这种情况, 我们忧心考虑这种占比大的那些国家, 这里才会有大客户, 以及高质量的客户更多
你看我下面这已经写好了, 用于判断国家买家资料, 用于判断这个行业下的这个国家, 是否有大客户, 这个板块大家一定要重视了
那么接下来我们就来讲一下关于在美国和同类目下他们偏好搜索的词是什么样的
首先你看这些热度的词这些涨幅的词我们可以去找到这些词然后再去判断的精准度用于发产品或者是用于推广对应的产品就可以了
那么这个维度的又不展开细细的讲了这里还有一个分端那么你可以通过这个分端来找的到
你的这些词到底是在哪个端口流量比较大
那么你在推广的时候APP的溢价可能就会有所起作用了
这个板块就不展开讲了
因为前面很多内容都会涉及到这个
前面我们已经讲了关于词的选择了
那么现在就到产品的选择了
那么在这个类目下
这个国家偏好的产品是哪种类型的产品
以及他们的产品有哪些属性风格
这个时候我们就可以挖掘这个国家偏好的产品款式
直接和公司现有的产品进行一个对标
找到公司潜力相似的产品链接
持续的积累资源去打造爆品
或者直接将这些款式用于发新的产品
然后直接推广快速找到潜力的链接
再重新打爆
也就是两条路径
第一条路径就是从我们店铺里面找相似的产品
数据比较好的去打造成爆品
第二个就是我们重新去找产品来发
重新从新品加速计划去推广来打造爆品
按照这两条路径去走就可以了
这个就是关于我们要找到目标国家访问和循环偏好
有交集的产品
一定要有交集的产品
因为有交集才代表着它是非常受市场欢迎的
而且已经被市场验证它是有需求的
再对这些有需求的产品进行打造爆品,就非常容易的成功了
这个就是关于我们在具体内幕,具体的国家下, 国家偏好这个内幕里面的哪一些款式的风格的产品
接下来就是到这个品类偏好, 也就是我们要掌握这个国家需求的品类和推广的资源, 倾斜到这些品类
比如说我们知道美国在这个品类下美国这个国家偏好的是更细维度的哪些品类
那么我们就可以倾斜我们的公车的资源或者是预算去推广这类产品
我们做店铺就是要找到市场偏好的品类
店铺在产品规划的时候和公车推广策略方面都要顺着这个市场的需求去推广
满足市场需求就行了
这里面有几个品类, 也就是美国它偏好的品类, 代表着它的一个流量的大小
那么通过品类的偏好, 知道当前这个国家需求哪些品类最为迫切, 以及现在这个国家重点品类切入的方向是哪些
有利于电部产品布局和直通的推广策略的一个制定, 在这些流量大的品类中倾斜更多的流量资源
比如说我们在这个类目下, 如果你看到的这些品类, 它跟这些发寻盘的品类有交集的时候, 那么你就可以快速的验证, 这个品类是非常受这个国家的偏好的, 所以说你在推广的时候, 或者是发产品的时候, 都应该集中资源去做这个品类优先
那么以上就是关于通过国家这个维度进行市场分析
那么接着我们到后台去看一下具体如何操作
首先我们打开的是第一个查国家
内幕你确定了吗
如果没有确定的话就按照这个先固定这个内幕
内幕固定了之后我们选择流量巨大的国家
比如说美国
点一下跳到美国
跳到美国之后
这里是不是有个买家画像分析
我这里先选一个
比如说我还是男装
我先把这个类目确定, 然后再把这个国家确定
确定的话, 月份的话, 我们选最近30天, 当然你也可以往前选
这样的话, 你可以得到很多数据, 然后进行每个数据对比, 你就能够知道
当前美国它是如何变化的
那么这个美国这里有终端, 还有MOQ, 这些我们就不讲了
你看这采购规模, 刚才我国众的强调了这个
一定要重视这个板块, 决定着买家大小和买家的
质量, 接下来就是搜索编号, 你看, 美国搜索什么样的词, 你看这些词, 加上这边这些词, 你可以整理应用
那么在下一步就是他们编号什么类型的产品, 你看这产品, 看到了吗
选择他们有交集的产品, 然后再去发布产品, 或者是重新推广产品
这些都是他的一些在平台上的一些数据的排名, 以及他的一些数据的占品
接着做了一个这些什么端口, 你都可以去看
偏向哪些端口, 这些板块都可以做非常细细的看, 接着就是品类的偏好, 比如说男装, 男装里面还有这么多品类, 你选择这两个交集的, 有交集的品类优先做, 一个是访问偏好说明这边流量很大, 询盘的排名的话, 这个跟这个交集, 上面这个跟下面这个交集, 就说明这个是流量大, 这个代表着迫切的需求, 也就是他一定会去发询盘问你,
发 TM, 或者是成交订单
所以说这两个要选择一个交集
接下来这报易数据的话
有些是没有的,有些是有的
就要看你自己的整体的数据了
接下来我们就来总结一下关于这两个路径的一些
思路,我们把它理顺一点,比如说第一个查行业, 也就是在我画的这个圈是行业的维度
在这个行业的维度里面去选择国家细分的品类
品类, 卖家, 以及产品, 在这个行业里面去分析这些细小的维度, 查国家呢, 首先我们确定的是这个国家, 比如说我画这个圈, 国家的维度, 在这个国家的维度加上, 你选这个类目已经固定了, 这个类目固定加这个国家, 那么在这个国家维度里面去分析这个国家的一个搜索编号词, 还有这个国家的编号产品, 还有这个国家的编号产品, 还有这个国家的编号的
三级类目, 或者是更小的类目, 这是大类, 这是小类, 如果这就是二级, 这个就是三级, 如果这是一级, 那么这个就是二级产品词, 它的一个偏好, 比如说刚才讲的那些NOQ, 还有采购量等等这些, 都是这个国家的偏好, 所以说, 我们先理解它的一个范围, 然后再根据它的范围里面去, 对一些比较细致的指标去分析, 那么我们就能够得到很多的
得到数据之后就能够帮我们去做决策
我们就知道先做什么
再到做什么
或者是说我们优先选择做什么
哪些我们可以不做
这样我们整个店铺的运营方向啊
以及我所要做的事情就非常清晰了
那么这个就是关于市场分析的一些比较简单的方法
我们这一次讲的方法主要是在站内分析
那么这些方法其实我们也可以迁移应用到一些账外的一些平台上面去找这些数据进行分析
那么这节课我们就先讲到这里
如果你对整个分析思路不是特别清楚的话
我建议你用手稿直接画点图
然后把整体的思路捋顺一遍
那么这样你去看数据你才会更加的清晰
这节课我们就先讲到这里
如果有什么其他的问题可以实现